hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
exploring the latest crazy revelations
about
dobby and his tragic backstory
dobby's true identity has already been
confirmed but he just revealed some
crucial
new information about his childhood and
his relationship
with his father dobby also publicly
exposed endeavor
and hawks for all of japan to see and
what he just did
may strike a major blow against the
entire hero society oh
and did i mention that an important
character just returned from the dead
let's get into it if you're enjoying
these boku no hero videos right here on
the channel please leave a like to let
me know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed be
sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications in case you don't know i
host a weekly anime podcast with noxtaku
and briggs and a bunch of other guests
it's called
the rant cafe anime podcast and right
now we have a deal with spotify so the
podcast is available for free
on spotify if you want to hear some
grown dudes just
ranting about anime definitely check out
the podcast
link in the description finally this
video will of course contain
boku no hero manga spoilers please
proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
installment of the story
we finally got the confirmation that
dabi
is indeed toya todoroki the eldest son
of endeavor
and shoto's older brother this was not
surprising to most of the fan base since
we've been
predicting this for over three years but
the way that this reveal took place
was very interesting and very impactful
and let's face it this whole todoroki
drama serves as a welcome distraction
for shigaraki
who desperately needs time to recover
from his injuries
now even though we already learned
dobby's true identity
we still didn't know how this seemingly
good-natured boy named toyatoroki
became the murderous villain dobby this
latest chapter finally answers some
of those questions and we are now
beginning to understand just how toya
went from the son of a top ranked pro
hero and an aspiring hero himself
to one of the most dangerous villains in
the country
first up we got an explanation about the
color of toya's hair
it seems that at first his hair was
indeed red like it was shown in the
anime but then his hair
slowly began turning white now obviously
didn't turn
white due to old age since toya was just
a kid
so i don't know if the color change was
some sort of genetic mutation and his
hair went from looking like his dad's to
looking like his mom's
or what is more likely is that his hair
started turning white because of the
tremendous amount of stress that toya
was putting on his body
during his training and yes it turns out
that in the early years of his life
toya was training to become a hero along
with his father
endeavor and it seems that at least for
a time they had a positive relationship
we see toyah actually smiling while
training with his dad
and he even asks endeavor to teach him
one of his super moves
endeavor then explains that toya was his
firstborn
but despite the fact that rey was his
mother toya wasn't born with any sort of
ice element
to his quirk at the time endeavour
believed that possessing both a fire
and ice element in your quirk is the
ultimate weapon
endeavour's firebased quirk is powerful
but it has a major drawback
if he overuses it endeavor overheats
but in theory someone who had both fire
and ice elements to their quirk could
use the ice side to prevent himself from
overheating
and this is what endeavour wanted to
achieve however
even though toya's quirk didn't have an
ice element
endeavour noticed that his fire quirk
was more powerful
than his own this actually makes sense
because a blue flame or the blue part of
a flame
is said to be the hottest part so it
makes sense that dobby's blue flames
would be more powerful than regular
flames
it seems that endeavour was hopeful that
toya would become more powerful than him
and that toya could be the one to one
day
overtake all might and of course we know
that endeavour has been obsessed with
surpassing all might for many years
but just in case toya couldn't surpass
all might
endeavor wanted to keep having more
children he was still holding out hope
that one of his children would be born
with a quirk that was equal parts fire
and ice and we know that this did
eventually occur with his fourth child
shoto in this chapter we finally learned
what happened to toya or at least what
endeavor and the others
thought had happened to him when he was
still a child
i would say not even in his teens yet so
i'm guessing between like the ages of 10
and 12
he apparently died in a massive fire
the fire occurred on a hill where
endeavour used to train
and the flame burned at such extreme
temperatures that even toyah's bones
were believed to have been turned to
ashes the only remains that were found
was a fragment of toyah's lower
jawbone and this led everyone to believe
that toya was dead
endeavour tries to explain this to dobby
he says that toya
has to be dead but dobby claims that no
he is alive and kicking even the
villains didn't know the truth about
dobby's secret identity
and they seem as surprised as everyone
else since endeavour still seems to be
doubting dobby's words
dobby basically says yo let's go on mori
and i will prove
that you are the father well he might as
well be saying that because dabi offers
to show endeavor a dna
test that proves that the likelihood of
them two being father and son
is 99.99 percent
in fact dobby already obtained a sample
of endeavors blood back in kyushu
and he used it to conduct a dna test
without
endeavors knowledge as we speak dobby
is publicizing the results of the test
in his public broadcast
proving to the entire world that he is
indeed the son of the number one pro
hero
during the broadcast dobby goes on to
explain that endeavor was an abusive
father who would get physical with his
family
including with his trophy son shoto
after exposing endeavour's true
personality
dobby asks whether this is the type of
person who should be glorified
as the number one pro hero endeavors
fanboys who are watching the broadcast
including that one kid from the pro hero
arc who looks like natsu from fairy tale
simply don't want to accept what dobby
is saying
in this critical moment for the hero
society
the people still want to believe in
endeavor and the other pro
heroes but dobby doesn't stop there
after exposing the number one pro hero
he goes on to expose the number two pro
hero
hawks apparently skeptic had recorded
the very moment in which hawks killed
twice
and skeptic then goes on to broadcast
that moment
fully uncensored for everyone to see
dobby massages the truth by claiming
that twice was crying and trying to run
away
and hawks still brutally killed him by
stabbing him in the back
dobby also claims that he tried to
protect twice but failed
this is obviously a skewed narrative
since we know that hawks killed twice in
order to prevent him from using sad
man's parade to murder who knows how
many heroes and other people
and we also know that hawks offered
twice a way out
but twice repeatedly rejected it after
reading this chapter it really seems
like dobby never really intended to
protect
twice it's much more likely that dobby
wanted hawks to kill twice so that he
could capture the footage
and then use that footage to make hawks
and the entire hero society
look bad it's highly unlikely that all
of this happening
and dobby capturing the footage is just
a big
coincidence it's much more likely that
dobby intended for all this to happen
from the start dobby then goes on to
accuse hawks of yet
another murder dobby claims that hawks
killed the number 3
pro hero best genius in order to prove
his loyalty to the villains and convince
them to trust him
and we were of course led to believe
that hawks was behind the disappearance
of
best genius but that was before we knew
that hawks
wasn't actually a villain hawks wasn't
really a bad guy and he definitely
didn't kill
best genius but more on that later in
order to further incriminate hawks
dobby reveals that hawks's own father
was a villain
a serial thief and murderer hox's father
was apparently caught by endeavour
and ever since then hawks's background
and identity were hidden from the public
because they didn't want the world to
know
that hawks was the son of a villain if
what dobby says here is true
it would definitely explain hawks's
admiration for endeavor
if endeavour saved hawks from a villain
father potentially unabusive
villain father then hawks would
definitely look at endeavor as a savior
and
as a replacement father figure overall
though
dobby's message to the people of japan
is simple
the heroes are not who you think they
are
they are not these selfless altruistic
people
they are liars and hypocrites who only
care about themselves
the heroes are deceiving the public and
they are prepared to lie
cheat and even kill to get what they
want
dobby is hoping that his broadcast will
cause the public to lose
faith in the number one pro-hero
endeavor and in all heroes
in general and at a time like this when
major villains have been wreaking havoc
in multiple cities losing faith in the
hero society as a whole could cause
widespread panic and chaos now
of course the people are not about to
start supporting the villains just
because they saw dobby's broadcast
i am sure that they still want the
heroes to win even if the heroes turn
out to be
less than perfect people but with that
said
if the people see that the heroes are
incapable of stopping the destruction
caused by the villains
and if they also become convinced that
the heroes are selfish sociopaths who
don't
actually want to help them then
desperation and panic
will certainly kick in we will likely
see widespread civil unrest and
instability
and that will only facilitate the
villain's goal of destroying the hero
society dobby then jumps down from
machias back and prepares to use
flash fire fist his father's own
super move against him shoto tells
endeavor to move
but endeavour is frozen he is stunned by
the revelation that dobby is his son
because in his heart of hearts he always
did believe that toya was alive
he just never imagined that toya had
become the notorious
villain known as dobby but before dabi
can lay waste to endeavor and the others
using endeavour's own technique he is
interrupted
by none other than best genius
just as i had predicted in my previous
videos best genius
was the person inside that aircraft
and he is now using his ability to
control fabric to control
those massive steel wires that were
stored on the aircraft
and as i speculated earlier best genius
is indeed using the wires to try and
restrain
machia as he arrives on the scene best
genius apologizes for being
fashionably late haha fashion joke and
that
is how this chapter ends it is now
confirmed
that hawks did not really kill best
genius
and i mean since we know that he was
only pretending to be a villain i'd
always assume that best genius was
indeed
alive i'm guessing genus just
disappeared for a while so that hawks
can pretend
to have killed him and use that as a way
to infiltrate the villains
this was definitely another fascinating
chapter and we might now
finally have a way to actually stop
machia
at least temporarily but even though
this chapter gave us
a lot of answers it also left us with
some pretty big questions
we now know that toya was believed to
have died in a fire on a hill where his
father would often train
but we don't know how exactly toya ended
up
in that situation how did someone with a
fire-based quirk
end up in a situation where he was
presumed to have died in a fire
and since we know that he didn't die
what happened to him
he was still a child when the fire
happened so where did he go
after the fire in terms of how toya
ended up in that fire
i am sure that we will get some more
information about it in the coming
chapters
but my own guess is this we know that
toya was still living with the todoroki
family when shoto was born
and he was with them for the first
several years of shoto's life
we also know from the latest chapter
that toya had a somewhat
positive relationship with his father at
least at first
and he seemed to be enjoying his
training in fact we
saw that toyah was even excited to learn
endeavour's moves
however in this chapter we also saw that
toya's training was taking a physical
toll
on his body his hair was turning white
his skin was getting burned from using
his quirk
and so on my guess is that once shoto
was born
and his quirk began to manifest
endeavours started paying more attention
to shoto
and he neglected toya because shoto's
quirk had both fire and
ice and there were probably thought that
choto was the better bet
for surpassing all might he might even
have been thinking of toya's well-being
when he came to this conclusion
toya's quirk clearly hurts his body when
he uses it
but shoto's ice ability would help shoto
avoid
the drawbacks of overheating so when
endeavour decided to focus most of his
energy on shoto
he might have been doing it because he
thought it was best for everyone
including toya but the young toya seemed
to be really enjoying
training with his father and so
endeavour's decision to focus on shoto
probably broke his heart and made him
extremely jealous
i am guessing that toya decided to train
on his own
so that he could get strong enough to
get his father's attention once again
he wanted to prove to his father that he
could be the one to surpass all might
and i am guessing that one day he took
his training a step
too far he overused his quirk lost
control
caused a massive fire and caused serious
injuries to himself
i have no idea what happened to his
jawbone but presumably that injury
was caused by the fire toya must have
been rescued from the fire by someone
and that someone presumably also treated
his injuries
i don't know if this someone was a
villain or a random person
but it is clear that eventually toya
concluded that what happened to him was
endeavour's fault
if endeavour hadn't neglected him for
the sake of shoto
toya never would have pushed himself so
hard and permanently disfigured himself
with his own quirk in the process of
trying to get stronger
this is just speculation on my part but
that's what i'm thinking
right now let me know what you guys
think how did toya
end up in that fire and who rescued him
and raised him after the fire don't
forget to leave your thoughts
down in the comments below finally what
do you think is going to happen with
machia now so far he has been an
incredible ace in the hole for the
villains
but did best genius just take him out of
the picture
since makia needs his master's orders
before
acting and shigaraki is currently
indisposed
due to his injuries it is possible that
genus plan
might work but again dobby's appearance
and the entire drama around him
is the perfect distraction for shigaraki
and so
this may give shikaraki just enough time
to recover
and rejoin the battle and of course if
shigaki recovers
he can also give orders to makia
honestly i can't wait to see what
happens next
and definitely let me know what you guys
think will happen down in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more boku no hero content right here
on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to animeapro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar i want to give a big
thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect liam thompson
pattay heffa
red-haired raven wrytheon yx emperor
otaku
thomas jones spidey life chanel and
baked buddhist
finally thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky cricket xp joe stanton
rathu in deora very gucci
jessica califond alicia octor hinokamian
water
bonnie parks florian joy and garcia jack
watches anime amanda c
deadly saint high school dxd 73 matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you believe that they add
value to you please consider supporting
us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these legendary
people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you